[Musique]
Monsieur l'ambassadeur Mohammed Amine
Nedjad, bonjour. Bonjour. Est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
? Oui, je suis l'ambassadeur d'Iran
Mohamed Aminjat.
Je suis maintenant près de 15 mois ici à
Paris. Donc
euh j'ai fait mes carrières
une partie à l'extérieur, une partie à
l'intérieur
et puis j'ai eu l'occasion de parler
avec vous. Mais euh
la fois précédente euh j'ai commencé par
la France et j'ai fini par la France
pour le moment et j'ai vécu aussi j'ai
j'ai fait en Afrique et j'ai fait en
Europe. Donc voilà. En résumé, monsieur
l'ambassadeur, on vous reçoit
aujourd'hui pour savoir que qu'est-ce
qui se passe, votre perception,
qu'est-ce qui se passe à Israël ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe en Iran ?
Pourquoi ? Comment ? On a vu une attaque
préventive.
Je ne sais pas si en droit
international, on peut appeler ça
légalement attaque et préventive dans la
même phrase. Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Pourquoi ils ont ils ont attaqué ? Oui.
En effet euh vous savez depuis 13 juin
tout le matin,
on a c'était un vendredi
euh que l'Israël a attaqué l'Iran.
Il a attaqué l'Iran par
euh le biais
des des bombardements aérien mais aussi
par le biais des des des
éléments sophistiques
euh
qui ont fait par
la l'instruction
des explosions et de la pénétration dans
le dans le milieux des
de foyers des des commandants de de
forces armées iranien
qui étaient avec leur famille dans leur
appartement et c'est pourquoi
quelques-uns parmi eux ont
euh euh perdu leur famille ensemble en
tout cas
et il y a eu aussi des scientifiques
iraniens qui ont été visés par les
Israéliens.
Il y a eu des installations euh de
gouvernement mais aussi bien il y a eu
des dégâts sur des euh bâtiments des
gens
privés ou les civils.
Donc euh voilà, c'est c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on a conçu en tout cas la
dans la dans le médias que voilà une
attaque a été faite.
C'était dans le temps où nous étions
dans le processus de négociation avec
les Américains. Sur quoi ? Sur
le nucléaire. En tout cas, le nucléaire
il y a eu des négociations le dimanche,
c'était le 2e en tout cas c'est le 6e
euh séance de négociation prévue à Rman.
Euh ils ont annoncé que c'est une guerre
préventive. Mais préventiv sur quelle
base juridique et sur quelle légitim
légitimation ? Voilà, c'est c'est ce
qu'on c'est ce qu'on se demande parce
que quand on regarde la charte
de
de l'Organisation des nation de l'ONU
sur l'article 2 recours à la force et
attaquer militairement attaquer un pays
la l'intégrité territoriale et
l'indépendance politique des pays sont
interdits. Mais une fois il est fait, il
faut que le conseil de sécurité comme le
garant de la faille de la sécurité
s'assoit, condamne et puis renverse la
situation à l'ordinaire, ce qui n'a pas
eu le cas.
Donc il n'y a pas vraiment une une si
vous voulez une base juridique légitime
même il n'y avait pas il a il n'y avait
pas une une logique et dans des
arguments qui pouvaient euh persuader
euh l'opinion publique internationale
les Iraniens que la l'intervention
militaire unilatérale
n'est pas accep table et a des
conséquences très graves aussi bien sur
le droit international que sur les euh
le si vous voulez le mécanisme de la vie
des pays sur la scène internationale et
puis ça complique aussi la vie des gens.
C'est vrai. Euh l'Israël est un pays
qui qui a eu dans son dossier des des
attaques
annonc en annoncé non annoncé
attaque visé des innocents
à peine euh
n'est pas encore achevé la ce qu'ils ont
fait à Gaza dans la bande de Gaza.
Mais ils ont commencé un autre guerre,
une autre guerre et une autre attaque,
une agression vraiment euh sauvage
contre les peuples iraniens. Donc voilà
ce qui s'était vraiment passé. Et puis
la même charte des Nations unies de de
l'ONU et les mêmes euh mécanismes
international
internationaux
prévoit
un un droit de la défense. Donc l'Iran a
commencé à user sa droit de défense
et on espère que vraiment la communauté
internationale comprenne et les
Israéliens aussi comprennent ce qu'ils
sont en train de faire et le peuple
israélien puisse euh parler à leur
dirigeants des de leur dire qu'une fois
ça suffit parce que euh l'Iran n'est pas
la Palestine, l'Iran n'est pas l'Irak,
l'Iran n'est pas euh la Syrie, l'Iran
n'est pas et même vous voyez euh euh ce
n'est pas vraiment un monde au 20e
siècle où un pays décide de faire
quelque chose et puis après il il
commence à agir brutalement avec des
armes sophistiquées. On sait bien que
qui est ce qui est derrière, qui est ce
qui aide, qui est-ce qui donne toutes
ces armes sophistiqué ? Mais les gens
ordinaires veulent veulent vraiment
vivre que ça soit en Israël ou que ça
soit dans les pays limitrophes ou dans
le pays de la région,
c'est ce n'est pas une manière de On va
on va on va rentrer dans l'interview. Je
vais me faire l'avocat du diable. Ouais,
bien sûr.
Les justifications qui ont été données à
l'opinion internationale, c'est vous
êtes proche d'un seuil d'enrichissement
d'uranium
de qualité militaire, que les
inspections de laa ont été arrêtées, que
vous êtes au seuil d'une menace
imminente pour l'État d'Israël.
On a vu ce que vous avez formulé des
raccourcissa si possible votre question
à ce que je puisse voir. On commence
avec ça. Oui. Allez-y. Oui. Qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez répondre à cette
angoisse de menace imminente,
d'enrichissement,
de qualité militaire, décentrifugeuse un
peu depuis Stocknet ?
OK.
Regardons euh pour euh vraiment
interpréter tout événement et tout
phénomène sur la scène internationale,
nous avons des instances légales sur
le système qui veille à ce que les
obligations des pays, mais aussi bien
les devoirs des pays et les droits des
pays soient sauvegardés et la paix, la
sécurité soit assuré
en ce qui concerne notre nos activités
euh
d'enrichissement uranium,
euh d'abord l'enrichissement uranium, ce
n'est pas à à lui seul un élément qui
peut aboutir à la bombe. C'est la
première. Deuxè, il n'y a pas un limite
au niveau de de l'enrichissement ni à la
qualité de de d'enrichissement
des équipements, je dis et puis il y a
aussi des conventions et de la la non
prolifération la traité de non
prolifération nucléaire
que l'Iran est un signateur
et puis tous nos activités était depuis
quand il y a eu aux années 50, il y a eu
des réacteurs expérimental américain en
Iran. On était toujours
harmonieusement
en coordination avec l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique.
Et cela était pour toujours.
à partir d'un moment, il y a eu des
besoins réels mais aussi bien en
perspective
pour
euh très précisément pour le
combustible, mais aussi bien pour ce qui
est dans l'agriculture, pour que ce qui
est dans le traitement des malades et
dans dans les différents et on sait très
bien que le nucléaire est un une source
de la science
qui est une science de demain avec
toutes ces problèmes de combustible
fossil euh
les problèmes d'environnement tout ça.
Donc les Iraniens ont choisi avec
l'appui de leurs chercheurs, de leurs
jeunes de de monter un équipement
d'enrichissement uranium.
Je vous donne un exemple. Il y a eu le
moment où nous avions besoin de
combustible pour le même
réacteur expérimental
acheté
aux États-Unis à l'époque du chat
qu'on avait besoin de d'enrichissement
de l'orion de 20 %.
personne n'était prêt à nous donner,
même les pays qui avaient déjà euh donné
bah en tout cas euh le même combustible
en Iran. C'est pourquoi à ce moment-là,
on a décidé d'augmenter l'enrichissement
avec les moyens que nous avons eu et
produire le combustible et puis
surmonter le problème.
Le même réacteur avait eu déjà devait
avoir 90 % d'enrichissement mais après
ils ont après la révolution, ils ont
fait un un changement. Donc ils ont
ils l'ont adapté à recevoir
un combustible avec l'enrichissement de
20 %. Vous voyez ? Donc mais sur le
pourcentage de d'enrichissement, il n'y
a pas une barrière, il n'y a pas un
limite.
À partir du moment, il n'y a pas eu il
n'y a pas l'épreuve
qu'un qu'un qu'une activité paraî est
dévié sur l'aspect militaire
et que c'est confirmé par l'agence de
l'énergie atomique comme un organe euh
adéquat pour vérifier et pour annoncer,
prévenir tout ça.
On peut avoir les enregistrements à
n'importe quel degré,
mais ce n'est pas ça ne montre pas une
intention euh négative pour aller vers
le nucléaire militaire, ce qui n'est pas
euh n'a pas une place dans notre n'avait
pas et n'a pas toujours dans notre
stratégie défensive parce que l'Iran Euh
nous avons expérimenté une guerre de vit
à ce moment-là. On était
bon un jeune révolution si vous voulez,
une jeune révolution. C'était la
décision du peuple. Ils ont choisi de
renverser le gouvernement du chat. qu'il
qu'il pensait et qu'il considérait euh
un régime
euh manipulé sous la domination tel ou
tel et corrompu. Je ne veux pas entrer
vraiment mais ils ont fait une
révolution mais tout après toute la
révolution c'était les agissements
manipulai de l'extérieur à l'intérieur
du pays.
moins d'un an et demi une guerre une
guerre toute azimus qui a duré 8 ans et
une grande partie de la ter du
territoire iranien était occupé et nous
avons perdu des centaines de jeunes des
des centaines de milliers de jeunes
iraniens qui ont participé dans cette
guerre pour neutraliser la l'attaque et
pour sauvegarder la l'intégrité
territoriale du pays.
Je vous coupe, je continue à me faire
l'avocat du diable. Je vais me mettre à
la place des Israéliens. J'ai vu qu'ils
avaient fait des attaques au camions
piégés,
qu'ils avaient une usine de drone dans
un bâtiment de trois étages en Iran pour
construire des drones. J'ai vu une
centaine de votre état major, une
centaine de personnes de votre étatmajor
liquidé avec soit des frappes
chirurgical, soit du bombardement,
avec des immeubles civils au milieu
d'immeubles civils.
Donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont quand même
du renseignement chez vous pour être
capable de faire ce type d'opération sur
place depuis très longtemps. Donc ils
ont du renseignement de terrain. Est-ce
que vous pensez qu'ils ont exfiltré de
l'information de terrain permettant de
pouvoir se présenter devant les
institutions internationales pour dire
"Nous avons les preuves que l'Iran est
en train de faire un enrichissement et
de monter sa bombe. C'est pour ça que
nous avons fait une frappe préventive.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec le
renseignement qu'ils ont, ils sont
capables de soutenir ça devant les
instances internationales ? Oui ou non ?
Regardons deux choses. La première ce
qu'il y a des éléments infiltrés,
exfiltré par l'Israël. Donc ça montre
qu'il y a de tels niveau de la mauvaise
volonté
pour instabiliser un pays indépendant ou
que vos services de renseignement sont
aussi mauvais que les nôtres. Comment ?
Ou que vos services de renseignement
sont aussi mauvais que les nôtres. Bon,
c'est possible, tout est possible. Mais
mais vous voyez, ils ont bon les il faut
que les nos services de renseignement
vraiment expliquent mais je vous
expliquerai ce que je comprends
sur ce sujet-là. L'Iran était est
toujours été un pays
qui
ne s'habitue pas de faire complot
vis-à-vis des autres peuples, des autres
pays. Donc les Israéliens vont vous dire
vous armez le ha, vous armez les outils.
Non, laissez-moi de de finir ça.
Donc c'est pourquoi pour nous jusqu'à
même dernièrement, il y a eu un effort
pour assouplir
le visa pour les étrangers. Donc
beaucoup de pays, beaucoup de des des
citoyens des différents pays pouvaient
acquérir le visa à l'aéroport de Teron
pour un mois, un mois et demi. Et puis
donc l'Iran n'était pas un pays
sécuritaire si vous voulez. Non, par
contre, le peuple iranien et le
gouvernement iranien voulait euh agir et
montrer un visage euh très paisible,
très
accueillant si vous voulez. Donc voyez
maintenant si un pays avec tous ces
moyens avec un complot, un plan bien
dessiné euh essaie de préparer euh le
terrain pour un cours à un gouvernement
ou à des pays ou à ses ses commandants.
Donc à ce moment-là,
rien ne peut vraiment être comme
garantie.
que
que la réglementation de la loi
internationale
la loi juridique international.
Maintenant si c'est un c'est le
gouvernement israélien, ce n'est pas la
première fois en Iran. Ils ont fait en
Malaisie, ils ont fait en Thaïlande, en
Iran dans beaucoup de pays, ils ont fait
de tel acte, voyez de terreur si vous
voulez. Donc à partir du moment, vous
donnez la bombe
à des personnes à des gens qui sont pas
l'homme de métier mais seulement comme
un comment dirais-je ? Voilà. Et vous
vous lui dites "Allez, mettez-la, allez
viser cet endroit.
C'est ce n'est pas terrorisme. C'est
quoi ça ? C'est terrorisme, c'est pour
propager la terre. C'est tuer les
innocents euh en en contrepartie de quoi
? De l'argent,
rien d'autre. Il y a eu combien de de
votre état major qui a été liquidé ? Il
y a combien de civils qui ont été tués
depuis le début des frappes israéliennes
en Iran ? Voyez, selon mes informations,
il y a euh un point de main
des dizaines
euh de commandants de forces armées qui
ont été visés dans leur foyer
et il y a euh à peu près euh 2050
tués
et Puis 1000 300 blessés jusqu'à ce
moment-là à côté dans la côté iranienne.
Il a eu des hôpitaux touchés, il y a eu
des chaînes de télé touché ou c'est que
des objectifs militaires qui ont été
touchés ? Non non non non. La télévision
iranienne est touchée juste il y a
quelques heures et il y a eu un hôpital
complètement touché dans un seul
immeuble. Le premier jour, il y a eu 65
tu civils parmi lesquels 20 enfants.
Donc c'était un bâtiment tout à fait
civil. Il y avait pas de QG militaire au
3è sous-sol du du de l'hôpital. Non,
nous nous n'avons pas. Vous voyez quand
vous regardez comme je vous ai dit euh
on avait jamais pensé à à mettre
les armes à l'abri des hommes. Donc ce
n'est pas notre culture. Quand vous
regardez maintenant les les clips sorti
de l'Israël, vous voyez que dans le
milieu des immeuble où vivent les gens
ordinaires, les civils, il y a des des
éléments de d'hommes de fer qui sont en
train de fonctionner. Ils protège leur
civil. Comment ils protègent leurs
civils ? Oui, mais mais en tout cas, ils
ils peuvent ils peuvent être aussi le
target d'une réponse à ce moment-là.
Qu'est-ce qu'il va protège leur civil et
Israël ? est tout petit. Donc c'est
comme si vous mettiez,
on va dire le le QG militaire israélien,
comme il y a pas beaucoup de place, ils
sont obligés de le mettre en pleine
ville. Ouais.
Pour justifier tout ça, on peut toujours
dire mais ça aussi donne un sentiment
que les autres aussi font la même chose.
C'est pourquoi quand à Gaza, au
territoire de Gaza, quand ils ont
bombardé un deux trois hôpitaux, ils
disaient que que c'était au sous-sol des
militaires comme eux tandis que ce
n'était pas le cas et ils n'ont pas
trouvé vraiment des des militaires ou
des des équipements militaires là-bas.
En tout cas, pour nous, en ce qui nous
concerne, euh bah les enrichissements
d'Uranium est une science
euh seul pour l'année 2024
euh tandis que nous avons 303 % de toute
l'installation
atomique dans le monde. Euh 3 % de
mondial appartient de l'Iran.
21 % des inspections,
ce sont des chiffres officiels, ont été
faits à l'Iran et les inspecteurs
étaient et sont toujours présents en
Iran. Vous savez peuvent aller partout.
Comment ils peuvent aller partout ? Bien
sûr, ils peuvent aller aller partout.
J'ai vu j'ai vu euh des communications
du pouvoir irraien montrant des super
boomkers à 800 m de profondeur avec des
missiles. Est-ce que vous cachez ? Non.
des centres d'enrichissement. Non, non,
non. Est-ce qu'on peut imaginer ou
est-ce que les Israéliens sont angoissés
de ne pas pouvoir détecter
ce qu'ils estimeraient être des centres
d'enrichissement ?
Regardons quand à 1980,
Israël a attaqué l'Irak. C'était le le
le centre aux Irak. C'était Mine France
ça non ? Made in France. Tout à fait.
Tout à fait. Mais c'était le même
argument quand ils ont attaqué la Syrie.
C'était le même argument. 2009 quand ils
ont attaqué Sarnet en Iran. C'était le
même argument. Et vous vous souvenez
qu'à 2012,
le premier ministre israélien
était présent en discours aux États aux
Nations Unies et il montrait que voilà
une grande partie de de la de travail
iranien est fini. Il reste qu'un qu'un
petit. Mais ça fait 40 ans qu'il dit ça.
Ah oui voilà voilà. Mais après non, ce
qui vous êtes plutôt lent à faire des
bombes quand même. Mince alors. Non, ça
fait 40 ans que vous êtes à 3 jours de
faire des bombes. Bien sûr. Qu'est-ce
que c'est que ce travail ? Oui. Non mais
mais la différence c'est que à 2015
quand nous avons été approchés
nous avons nous nous sommes approchés
avec les États-Unis de discuter avec
pour trouver une solution.
Qu'est-ce qui était la question d'abord
? La question était après plus de 10 ans
de négociation à l'impasse, pourquoi
Iran disait nous n'avons pas l'intention
de fabriquer la bombe atomique.
Et puis il disait l'Occident, les
Européens que nous vous ne devez pas
avoir l'enrichissement
tandis que l'enrichissement d'uranium
c'est un droit des signataires de de la
traité de non prolifération.
avant 2015, on s'était mis d'accord, ils
se sont reconnus que l'Iran peut avoir
euh
la
comment la technologie d'enrichissement
et les installations d'enrichir uranium.
C'est à ce moment-là
que qu'un travail très
fort a été fait et par la chance et par
l'inspection encore plus forte. Mais à
la fin du compte, ils ont vérifié, ils
ont confirmé qu'il n'y a pas une
déviation vers militaire.
C'est pourquoi on a signé un accord. On
a signé un accord en contrepartie
d'une d'une retenue si vous voulez
volontaire de l'Iran. C'est strictement
écrit dans l'accord euh de d'enrichir
d'enrichissement d'enrichir dans un taux
euh 3,67
%.
Les sanctions doivent être levées.
Maintenant, s'ils sont s'ils ont été
levés ou euh il y a eu de problèmes,
c'est c'est un autre chose. une autre
chose, mais on était 3 ans dans une
situation que nous pouvions exporter nos
produits, que nous pouvions avoir un
commerce plus ou moins euh
à l'aise si vous voulez.
Et puis de l'autre côté, c'était une
comment dirais-je une inspection euh
fréquente continue. Pendant 3 ans, 15
rapports de l'AE
à l'Agence Internationale de l'ergie
atomique a confirmer pendant donc 15
rapports que les activités nucléaires
iraniennes ne sont pas en direction de
l'armement ou que ce soit. Est-ce que
vous avez dans l'inspection complète,
est-ce que vous avez déposé une plainte
ou du moins une requête auprès des
Nations- Unies pour dire on a été
attaqué, on exerce notre droit de
défense,
est-ce que les institutions, est-ce que
d'autres pays vous ont apporté du
soutien ? J'ai vu que la Finlande avait
dit que c'était pas légitime. J'ai vu
que les Chinois disaient "Les Israéliens
sont en train de passer une ligne
rouge." D'ailleurs, est-ce que des
dispositifs nucléaires ont été touchés
en Iran récemment ? Est-ce que la IEA a
a rouspé de voir des dispositifs
iraniens nucléaires toucher ? Première
question, est-ce que vous avez déposé
une plainte ? Deuxème question sur votre
de votre droit à la ripost. Est-ce que
vous quand vous tapez sur AIFA ou Tela
Aviv, est-ce qu'il y a des bâtiments
civils qui ont été touchés ? Est-ce que
tous vos missiles arrivent ? Est-ce que
le dô de fer neutralise 95 % de vos
missiles ? Est-ce que vos missiles sont
peut-être moins précis ? Oui, regardons,
il y a un mécanisme. Donc dès dès la
tech, nous avons annoncé, nous avons
fait notre ministre des affaires
étrangères a écrit une lettre au
président du conseil de sécurité aussi
bien que le secrétaire général des
Nations Unies pour annoncer cette
violation flagrante de du droit
international.
Et puis on avait des communiqués, on
avait informé toutes les partenaires,
toutes les partis concernés sur cette
violation de de droit international,
cette agression vraiment illégale,
illégitime. C'est tout ce qu'on avait
fait. En ce qui concerne la notre
réponse, notre réponse d'abord était euh
comme toujours
euh avec une retenue mais en toujours
évitant, c'est le cas toujours euh des
milieux civils. Par contre,
d'où l'attaque est venue ? L'aéroport de
quel ou la base militaire de quel où les
avions F35 américains euh prenaient les
les bombes euh voilà évacuer sur l'Iran
? C'était notre réponse
initiale
et à partir du moment où ils ont
commencé à bombarder les les
infrastructures
économiques énergétiqu énergétique
économique énergétique. Oui. Voilà. Donc
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on a commencé à
faire la même chose. Donc cela toujours
euh dans une vision euh de prévention,
d'aggravation de la situation et de
l'escalade. Des escalades bien sûr. Donc
c'était c'était notre euh parce que nous
nous n'avons ça a pas l'air de marcher
hein. Comment ça a pas l'air de marcher.
Oui.
Vous voyez, nous comme l'Iran,
nous essayons toujours avoir une une
approche et un comportement responsable
et nous ne voulions pas vraiment euh
faire en sorte que la paix et la
stabilité déjà affaiblie dans la région
soit encore mise au pied. C'est pourquoi
nous n'avons pas déclaré les guerres.
C'était une guerre déclarée
unilatéralement,
illégalement et illégitimement par
Israël contre l'Iran. Nous ne sommes pas
les voisins l'un et l'autre et les
accusations doivent être prouvées mais
pas par une imagination
quelconque mais par les instances
internationaux et nous étions toujours
en en disponibilité que ça soit avec
l'agence ou avec l'ONU et nous avons
essayé d'avoir de meilleures relations
avec des instances internationaux comme
nation national comme l'ONU, ce qui
n'est pas le cas
d'Israël. Rappelez, vous vous rappelez
de Coline Powell avec la fiole d'Antrax
devant les États-Unis, de moins devant
les Nations Unies. Est-ce que si je vous
écoute au bénéfice du doute, vous vous
nous dites que Israël n'a aucune preuve
que vous vous êtes sur le chemin à très
court terme d'une menace imminente de
bombes nucléaires. Vous réclamez les
preuves d'eux.
Est-ce qu'ils ont intoxiqué les autres
chancelleries dites occidentales avec du
renseignement
intoxiqué, tronqué ? Est-ce que vous
pensez ça ? Je vous avais donné un
exemple sur le le discours de monsieur
Netanahou mais chaque fois qu'il y a eu
un sentiment, une imagination
de danger si vous voulez par les
Israéliens, ils ont commencé à fabriquer
les les prétextes, les justifications.
En Irak, c'était la même chose. Congrès.
Peut-être vous avez vu le les arguments
de monsieur Nanou à l'époque qui disait
que voilà, il faut que les États-Unis
fassent ça. Il y a les armes de
destruction massive. L'Irak est en train
de faire ceci et cela mais après on n'a
rien trouvé comme l'épreuve. Mais le
temps était passé ça. L'Irak a été
infligé. Il y a eu de 1 million de
morts. Il y a eu des trillions de
d'euros investis par les Américain. Mais
à la fin du compte, il y a eu une
déstabilisation,
une une un peuple brisé, une une
situation vraiment désastreuse pour le
peuple iraakien.
Ils veulent encore répéter encore une
fois parler des des États-Unis. Là,
actuellement, il y a un exercice qui est
en train de se passer qui s'appelle
Trident, quelque chose comme ça.
Excusez-moi, j'ai oublié la chose. Nous
avons vu une petite trentaine d'avions
ravitailleurs se diriger vers l'Europe.
Qui dit avion ravitailleur dit peut-être
chasseur, dit peut-être bombardier. On
voit un porte-avion américain se
rapprocher de chez vous.
Vous percevez ça comment ? Quelles vont
être vos mesures pour vous protéger ?
Est-ce que vous allez bloquer le D3
d'ormous ? Est-ce que vous allez couler
des bateaux dans le D3 d'Ormouse ?
Est-ce que vous allez fermer
définitivement le D3 d'Ormous ? Euh euh
les ambassades américaine dans la région
été évacué de peur de d'avoir des
rétorsions iraniennes. Comment vous
percevez la chose ? Et ensuite,
j'aimerais qu'on parle de la Chine et de
la Russie, des alliances et de de des
alliés iraniens.
Regardons, pour nous, la paix est un
élément primordial pour nous et pour la
région. Comment on dit paix en iranien ?
En farci sol. Sol
si on a un arabe, c'est la même chose.
C'est pourquoi on a fait un on a eu un
comportement tout à fait responsable
et on a essayé avec les pays de la
région de trouver vraiment les
mécanismes et les moyens de garantir
l'instabilité la paix dans les régions
avec par nous-mêmes les gens de région
parce que à la fin du compte c'est la
vie de nos peuples, c'est le
développement de notre pays qui dépend
de ça. Bien sûr, vous m'autorisez ? Ah
bah sinon si si vous voulez pas que je
vous Ah si si, je veux que vous
continuez mais je vous coupe juste là.
On va vous rétorquer mais vous financez
les outils, vous armez le Hamas, vous
armez le esbola vous déstabilisez la
région. Qu'est-ce c'est pour ça que je
suis obligé de vous vous le dire, c'est
l'autre côté du miroir. Nous on vous
écoute. Ouais. On écoute les arguments
des autres. On respecte le droit
international.
quand ils vous disent ça, que vous vous
êtes un élément déstabilisateur,
que vous êtes le régime des mol, que
vous pendez tout le monde, que il y a la
peine de mort, que vous êtes l'axe du
mal.
Oui. Maintenant sur le la garantie de la
paix dans
le 23 de ou de la golfsque,
l'Iran avait et a et aura toujours
un comportement responsable
en gardant
en mémoire et en pratique la nécessité
de sauvegarder
la paix et la stabilité dans ce parti du
monde où il y a
des des des intérêts économiques pour
tout le monde et dans les premiers lieux
pour l'Iran. Donc prétendre que l'Iran
veut faire cela, veut faire cela, c'est
pas concevable même.
En ce qui concerne les menaces,
nous
ce n'est pas la première fois nous avons
été attaqués par les étrangers.
Même dans ces 50 dernières années, je ne
veux pas aller plus loin à la deuxième
guerre mondiale avant tout ça. Mais le
peuple iranien était debout avec tous
leurs moyens
d'expulser et de
neutraliser
une invasion, une agression quelconque.
Donc ça n'a pas été changé.
Donc je suis certain et on est vraiment
on est sur les pieds de nos jeunes qui
vont battre s'il y a une menace comme
ils sont en train de le faire euh sur
contre les agressions
récentes actuelles.
Donc il y a sans doute qu'il y aurait
une unanimité du peuple iranien devant
une telle. Euh la trahison
est mauvaise mais chez nous les Iraniens
est mauvaise et quand même péché très
grave. Mais là il y a beaucoup de gens
qui vivent dans le péché. Vous votre on
liquide pas 100 personnes de de votre
état major sans avoir des traîtres. Oui,
c'est vrai. Non, il y en a c'est Ça
c'est vrai. Vous voyez, on dit on dit
que vot votre corps d'état, votre
présidence est est infiltré par le
Mossad jusqu'aux plus hautes sphères.
Mohamed Arménie Nedjad disait que ils
avaient recruté euh quelqu'un à la tête
des services de renseignement et c'était
un agent double. Oui, vous voyez les
tentatives de déstabilisation
menée par Israël était
depuis toujours en Iran et et dans tous
les pays de la région. Ça c'est une
chose. Deuxième chose, c'est peut-être
aussi parce qu'ils sont angoissés.
Ah, ça c'est ça c'est leur sentiment.
Mais mais peut-être il y a aussi des
sentiments
personnels d'une d'un échec ou d'un mort
de quelqu'un de c de leur proches, je ne
sais pas. Mais en tout cas, en ce qui
nous concerne,
quand
monsieur Trump est sorti de l'accord
nucléaire avec qu'on avons signé et que
nous avons tous
étidés de sauvegarder cet accord,
il a commencé de d'exercer une pression
maximale. Impression maximale, ça veut
dire de faire l'isaniens
de plus en plus difficile.
Euh pour un an, on a on a difficile
comment
vous voyez ce sont des résultats. Je
vous dis quand un peuple souffre il
essaie de comprendre pourquoi
et quand il voit que les autres se
développent développent mais lui est en
souffrance ou bien il vient contrer
leurs dirigeants ou bien ils vont
trouver des moyens de de se satisfaire
et puis là il y a une une demande si
vous voulez de vendre les services
Et c'est là que les Israéliens ont
profité par l'argent de les acheter
et les gens bon tout le monde n'est pas
patriote, tout le monde n'est pas
choviniste. Donc, ce sont des points de
faiblesse que ce type de des gil et des
des pays
utilise pour en tout cas avancer leur
leur projet de déstabilisation de de
partage de de sem
la la
la zizanie comme on dit tout à fait la
zisanie tout dans le pays
Donc voilà, nous avons et tout le monde
a mais bon nous avons été le victime
d'une d'un appuvrissement
issu de de l'embargo et de cette euh
pression maximale qui a privé notre
peuple de d'exploiter leurs ressources
et puis d'essayer d'avoir des relations
et des entraides nécessaires avec les
autres pays par exemple. exemple avec
l'Europe comme il y a eu des manque de
transfert de l'argent on ne pouvait pas
ni vendre nos produit notre huil notre
pétrole notre gaz et puis nous ne
pouvions pas acheter les nouveaux
équipements rénover notre nos nos nos
installation nos équipements industriels
qui étaient nécessaires pour créer de
l'emploi et les jeunes euh une partie
des jeunes peuvent trouver de un moyen
de d'étudier à l'intérieur du pays ou
aller à l'extérieur travailler mais pas
tout le monde. Il l'Iran 80 près de 90
millions d'habitants et avec les jeunes
gens bien éduqués, bien investis par
l'État, par leur famille, propre
famille. La moyenne d'âge, la moyenne
d'âge du peuple iranien, c'est quel âge
? Ça doit être
40 entre 40 et 50 je crois. Pratiquement
90 millions de personnes, c'est ça ? Oui
oui oui. Près de 800 90 millions de
personnes maintenant. Donc vous voyez
c'est il crée un climat, un
environnement où il y a mécontentement,
il y a la faiblesse et la vulnérabilité.
À ce moment-là, ils viennent euh
utiliser comme moyen de de pression ou
de complot. Euh c'est pourquoi sinon les
Iraniens ne sont pas les gens qui
trahent très facilement leur pays. Que
l'Iran est un vecteur de déstabilisation
dans la région parce que vous financez
des groupes armés,
le Hamas, le le Esbola que vous avez vos
vos relais au Liban, que vous encerclez
Israël, que l'Iran a décrété que Israël
c'était le grand Satan qu'il fallait les
détruire. Ça peut angoisser aussi des
gens. La 2e partie de votre question que
je voulais vous dire, regardons.
Euh on peut toujours euh mettre
étiquette sur un groupe terroriste
et puis après comme terroriste, il faut
maintenant battre
euh
tout en renonçant de voir vraiment la
racine des problèmes.
L'Iran a des amitié avec lebouah.
À l'époque, il n'y a pas eu debah.
avantboll en 1980
quand il y a eu l'occupation israélienne
là, il n'y a pas eu de d'une résistance
si vous voulez euh au Liban pour
défendre la le territoire libana des
incursions euh
israéliennes, continuelle israélienne
parce que c'était toujours une fois à
cause des Palestiens, une fois avec à
cause de ça avec tous ces prétextes
parce que tout le monde doit vivre dans
la peur. Il prenaient quand même des
requêtes sur la tête. Quand ça les
Israéliens ils prenaient Oui, mais non,
je vous expliquerai.
Euh
donc c'était une amitié mais Hbllah
était et toujours un groupe qui défend
l'intégrité territoriale libanais contre
c'est c'est un groupe politique mais
aussi militaire qui défendent le Liban
qui n'est pas contre Israël
et qui n'avait pas pendant sa vie de
plus de 20 ans qu'il n'avait lancé même
un requête vers Israël.
Ça c'est au moment où Israël a commencé
à tuer des Palestiniens à Gaza que
l'esbol a montré sa solidarité. Mais
n'était pas notre pupette et n'est
toujours pas ils ont leur pupette, vous
avez dit pupette, marionnette,
marionnette. Marionnette ou des gens qui
vraiment sont bah sont dans le à l'oré
dans le notre ordre de faire quoi où ce
soit. Nous nous-mêmes
nous n'avons et nous ne voulons pas nous
intermellerer dans les affaires des pays
indépendant surtout l'oliv surtout nous
vraiment nous n'avons pas une telle
culture parce que nous n'avons pas des
intérêts compliqués pour nous permettre
d' gérer dans les affaires des autres.
Lea a décidé d'aider les Palestiniens.
Maintenant, s'il y a quelque chose, ça
dépend à eux. Ce sont leurs décisions.
Ce n'est pas notre décision. Je ne veux
pas entrer en détail de ce qu'Israël a
fait avec eux, comment il a plané, il a
tué des innocents, tout ça. Mais ce
n'est pas pour le moment. En Hamas, vous
savez bien, c'est une organisation
palestinienne sunnite
n'ayant pas une relation historique avec
l'Iran. C'est une solidarité entre les
musulmans, entre nous et les gens qui
qui sont souffert souffert et qui ont
été soufferts. Ce n'est pas de 7 octobre
mais dès le début de la de la création
de l'État d'Israël. Et puis les houssi
Yamani c'est la même chose. Ils ont leur
leaders ils ont leurs moyens
ils décident bien. Bon vous regardons
d'abord on peut toujours nier les drones
nier les armes. Mais les armes peut
trouver partout dans le monde quand il y
a une volonté, un argent, quand il y a
vraiment une menace.
Je ne veux pas vraiment défendre de
défendre ici les Yéméites. Ce sont à eux
de défendre leurs intérêts. Comment ils
avait subi, quelle pression, quelle
humiliation. Ce sont à eux de le faire.
Mais c'est toujours c'est facile de dire
que voilà, tel pays et marionnette de la
de telle puissance ou de l'autre et
depuis commencer à affaiblir, à
reprocher à préparer le terrain, paver
le la voie pour l'abattre et le donc je
voudrais qu'on parle de vos alliés, on
peut toujours lier l'un et l'autre mais
je voudrais qu'on parle de vos alliés.
La Chine. Oui. La Russie peut-être.
Ouais. Ils vous ont appelé ? Qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont dit ? On voit Poutine se
proposer d'être médiateur.
La Chine, qu'est-ce que dit la Chine ?
Comment va se passer l'avenir pour vous,
pour l'Iran et la région ? Regardons
monsieur Sky.
Euh nous avons des relations
euh basées sur le respect mutuel
et sur l'intérêt commun
avec presque tous les pays du monde.
Avec quelques quelques pays, nous avons
des similitudes dans les positions
politiques. Nous avons une à proximité
dans le voisinage.
La Russie
est un voisin pour nous, un voisin
proche pour nous. La Chine,
c'est une grande civilisation, un grand
peuple avec une avancée très
intéressante dans les années passées
avec qui nous avions toujours des
relations basées sur le respect, sur la
complémentarité économique, sur une
harmonie autant que possible politique
dans les positions et sur la scène
internationale dans les grandes
questions euh euh globales.
Donc à partir du moment il pense que
ils seraient euh ils seraient dans leurs
intérêts
de prendre un pas
euh à nos yeux
dans le cadre de la paix et la sécurité
et dans le cadre de la justice.
il sera bienvenu toujours aux yeux des
Iraniens.
Mais il n'y a pas
si vous demandez est-ce qu'il Non, nous
n'avons pas d'une manière si on aurait
eu une alliance, bon on pouvait toujours
garder la toute notre indépendance. Et
puis vous avez une alliance russe ? Non
non, pas il n'y a pas une alliance, il y
a il y a une entente, il y a des accords
parce que les Russes les Russes nous ont
aidé euh
surtout après la guerre
notre guerre quand nous avons perdu
beaucoup de nos moyens de défense. Vous
avez aidé aussi les Russes avec
l'Ukraine ? Non. Comment vous avez aidé
aussi les Russes avec l'Ukraine ? Non
non, on éétait pas on était pas à côté
de des Russes contre l'Ukraine, mais on
avait
regardons quand la guerre Iran Irak a
été finie à 1984
euh nous avions perdu approximativement
toutes nos euh
utiles défensives.
C'était une guerre vraiment inégale.
À partir du moment où nous avions besoin
de sécuriser notre espace aérien
et de renforcer, fortifier un peu notre
défense dans les frontières.
C'est à ce moment-là que l'Occident
étant notre
euh comment provider comment dire
fournisseur principal,
ils ont hésité de le faire. Ils ont
renoncé de le faire.
C'est pourquoi nous avions eu une nous
avions commencé une coopération avec les
Russes très mesuré, très encadré
et
c'est à partir du moment notre
coopération dans le différents domaines
que ce soit la formation ou achat des
des équipements tout ça on commençait
médicaments dans tout dans tous les dans
tous les secteurs mais mais le volumes
d'échange entre nous n'était pas trop
grand à à cause de la de la nature de
nos économies parce que nos économies
étaient toujours ils étaient ils sont
toujours le producteur de pétrole et
gaz. L'Iran c'est aussi donc il n'y a
pas la complémentarité par contre avec
les autres. Et c'est pourquoi dire que
non, l'Iran a aidé,
c'est une prétention
et encore une fois une accusation et
puis préparer à des à des montages de
de complot ou de des activités contre
l'Iran et les intérêts des Iraniens.
Sinon,
ni la Russie
est autant
faible
pour dépendre à à des
industries ou à des fabrications
iraniens très mesurées, très peut-être
pas très sophistiqué et nous nous
n'avions rien comme animosité avec les
Ukrainiens.
Par contre,
nos relations étaient toujours
respectueuses avec eux réciproquement et
nous avions de bonnes relations de
coopération et de commerce avec eux dans
différents domaines. Le fait le fait que
vos installations énergétiques se
fassent cibler par les Israéliens,
est-ce que ça a tendance un petit peu à
attendre la Chine qui est un de vos
principaux clients en terme
d'hydrocarbure et de marché énergétique
? Est-ce que les Chinois vous ont appelé
? Pas vous personnellement bien sûr,
mais est-ce qu'ils vous ont appelé en
disant voilà
ça va être problématique pour nous que
vous vous mettiez à boîter sur la
l'approvisionnement d'hydrocarburant ?
Non, vraiment euh vous voyez, il faut
être réalistique.
La part du pétrole iranien à cause de
cet embargo
et de plus en plus diminué
euh que ça soit dans le dans
l'approvisionnement de la de la d'une
grande économie comme la Chine ou dans
la fourn fournition fourniture de de de
l'ensemble de l'énergie mondiale.
que nous nous produisons maintenant le
pétrole. En tout cas, nous nous vendons
nous dans les dans les quantités très
modestes
pas très élevées.
Maintenant, c'est vraiment cette
quantité est tellement importante pour
la Chine à cause de cette question. Je
ne sais pas s'il y a eu des contacts
encore, je ne sais pas. Mais mais en
tout cas, comme je vous ai dit, euh nous
on dans cette épreuve
que nous vivons maintenant, on ne compte
que sur nos peuples et nos jeunes et
notre capacité défensive qui peut voilà.
Où est-ce que l'escalade face ? Où
est-ce que l'escalade peut nous emmener
tous, vous, le monde occidental, les
Iraniens, on voit les Anglais proposer
de l'aide logistique, même des chasseurs
pour protéger euh Israël. On voit euh
des portesavion, des ravitailleurs
commencer à se concentrer par là.
Qu'est-ce que l'Iran ? Jusqu'où ?
Comment ?
Regardons euh d'un point de vue, selon
notre point de vue, il n'y a besoin de
rien
parce que si le prétexte
est
la menace contre l'Israël, l'Iran n'a
jamais menacé l'Israël. Euh certains ont
dit que vous vouliez anéantir Israël.
Non, certains peut toujours prétendre,
mais il faut il faut les éléments. Et
pourquoi nous devons euh anéantir un
pays, un euh un peuple avec qui nous
n'avons rien comme animosité
parce que s'ils sont ils sont juifs, ils
sont nos frères et sœurs. Il y a
beaucoup de juifs àant. Ben c'est la
deuxème communauté juive
dans le Moyen-Orient après l'Israël.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils disent en ce moment ?
Non, ils ont même aujourd'hui, il y a eu
de chefs religieux qui religieux
de la communauté juive qui a condamné,
qui a demandé à des forces armées de
faire face à cette euh agression
israélienne. Non, ce n'est pas parce que
c'est ce n'est pas une question de d'une
communauté dans un pays ou pas, mais
c'est c'est une question de justice et
de règles internationale, de la loi
internationale. Euh qui est-ce qui peut
vraiment euh approuver une agression
sans aucune raison ? Nous nous avons dit
et nous avons montré
comme je vous ai dit par le biais de
travail de l'agence que notre l'agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique que
notre activité n'a pas une nature
militaire n'avait pas et n'a pas même
dans les moments difficiles. On est prêt
à à à prouver comme on avait prouvé,
comme je vous avais dit, l'Iran est un
des membres
responsables de la traité de non
prolifération. Je peux vous couper ?
Non, c'est plus imaginez, j'appelle des
copains, euh je leur dis bon, on va
dire, imaginez-vous que je sois copain
avec la DGSE française.
Je leur dit l'Iran veut montrer pattees
blanche, veut montrer qu'elle a rien à
se reprocher. Est-ce que vous avez une
liste de sites à visiter ou que vous
vous angoissez pour savoir ce qu'ils
font là-bas, si c'est une cuisine ou si
c'est un centre d'enrissement ? Est-ce
que vous êtes prêts ? Si vous recevez
une liste de sites à visiter à donner
carte blanche, allez-y, visitez ce que
vous voulez et faites votre rapport.
Regardons, c'està-dire pas la on va
prendre, admettons que la France puisse
être une troisème voie de paix. Si la
DGSE dit "OK, je vous appelle, on a ça,
ça, ça qu'on veut visiter parce que on
est angoissé, on n'arrive pas avec nos
satellites à voir jusqu'au fond. Est-ce
que vous nous ouvrez les portes
Regardons
euh ce n'est pas dans ce cadre là que
les choses fondent sur la scène
internationale.
Les français, les américains, les
Anglais, les autres ont les inspecteurs
dans le cadre de l'agence de l'énergie
atomique internationale de l'énergie
atomique.
dans les directeurs et les experts, il y
a des hommes de tous les pays.
La dernière le dernier rapport de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
atomique
a posé quelques inquiétudes
à vous ou à eux. Non, à nous. À nous à
l'Iran. Quel type d'inquiétude ? L'Iran.
Oui, je vous dis. et il a il a dit que
il y a deux deux cas
quatre cas
deux ne sont pas inquiétants et les
quatre remontent aux années avant 2000
quatre sites aux années avant 2000 que
la gence avait trouvé quelques éléments
ou quelques
radiation
sur les dans dans le dans le dans
l'environnement de là et que l'Iran doit
expliquer est-ce qu'ils ont est-ce que
ces moyens ont été utilisés pour étaient
entré dans le dans le cycle où il n'a
pas été utilisé tout ça mais tous
remontai à 2000 avant l'année 2000
à 2015 quand on voulait
entré dans une dans un accord avec les
Européens, cinq pays,
trois pays européens, les États-Unis, la
Chine, la Russie. Un grand question
était supposer des activités
euh supposé militaires ou
suspectés si vous voulez.
Donc, ils ont donné des listes, nous
avons donné les explications, nous avons
donné les accès tout tout et à la fin
ils ont dit "OK, on a entériné toutes
les questions du passé et puis pour
l'avenir c'est ce système là." Donc
l'Iran accepte volontairement de euh de
obligatoirement
ce qui est normal les rang âgés dans le
cadre de traité de non prolifération.
Vous avez des contacts avec les
Israéliens ? Non non, ils ont cherché à
avoir des contacts avec vous avant de
taper. Est-ce que vous vous avez cherché
à les contacter pour le dire bon on va
éviter aucun rapport ?
aucun rapport nous n'avons pas les
relations diplomatiques avec eux nous
n'avons pas des des liens de contact
avec eux et est-ce que vous avez une
troisième bande pour leur parler un
autre pays
nous avions en train de parler avec les
États-Unis
toujours une liaison de parler avec les
Européens même avant l'arrivée de
monsieur Trump on avait en fait sa
victoire dans l'élection on avait
commencé négociation avec trois pays
européens et on a fait cinq fois des
négociation
au niveau des vice-ministres et
directeurs
politiques des ministères des affaires
étrangères. Donc, ils peuvent toujours
s'ils ont la volonté de savoir vraiment
ce qui se passe sur le terrain. Pour
nous, l'accès comme je vous ai dit,
l'accès est garanti pour les inspecteurs
selon les coopération en place et sur
place que je vous ai dit et une grande
partie de l'inspection mondiale se fait
en Iran. Votre réponse militaire
concernant les bombardements sur Terran.
Ça va durer combien de temps ? Est-ce
que vous allez continuer tant que les
Israéliens vous bombardent, vous allez
continuer à à répliquer ? Est-ce que
vous avez, je dirais pas une vengeance,
mais venger vos hommes ? Combien de
temps ça va durer cette histoire ?
Regardons euh est-ce que l'objectif
israélien c'est de faire basculer votre
République ? Ah sûrement. Sinon, quelle
quelle justification pour telle telle
attaque et telle telle décision et telle
attaque ? Mais regardons sur la dans la
loi la loi internationale
euh il y a un droit de réponse.
Mais là un droit de réponse. Le droit
international, vous avez bien vu depuis
les 10 dernières années, les 20
dernières années, les occidentaux ont
aussi tendance à instrumentaliser le
droit international pour désigner les
méchants. Oui. Donc vous en tant qu'ir
quand vous avez vu la Libye, l'Irak,
l'Afghanistan et n hein, vous avez
confiance encore au dans le droit
international ? Non mais vous voyez
c'est votre dernier rempart. Non non, ce
n'est pas le cas. Je voulais vous dire
que en tout cas pour un comportement sur
la scène internationale,
il faut qu'il y ait un cadre juridique
et c'est bon pour tout le monde. Vous on
peut dire que pour les plus puissants ça
n'a rien à voir. Il il instrumentalise
ou tout ça ? Mais bon Tony Blair il est
en prison. Non George Bouche il est en
prison. Non non non vous avez raison. Je
vous donne complètement raison. Mais
pour nous l'Iran, vous allez m'attirer
des problèmes. Si vous dites que j'ai
raison, vous allez m'attirer des
problèmes ? Pourquoi ? Parce que on va
dire les Iraniens donnent raison. Non,
je vous dis vous vous êtes votre pensée,
votre analyse est respectée par moi si
c'est vraiment
n'est pas compatible avec celle de mien.
Mais je voulais vous dire que nous nous
avons un droit de réponse parce que nous
avons été agressés. Ici, c'est un droit
de réponse.
Ce droit de réponse est exercé par la
volonté du peuple et par la nature de de
de ce type de phénomène. On va le faire
à partir du moment comme notre ministre
avait annoncé lequel l'Israël s'arrête
de d'agresser à partir du moment où on
peut voir
les modalités, les choses, les
négociations.
Je pense que c'est très tôt pour ça
parce qu'il faut
qu'ils aient un sentiment qu'on ne peut
pas très facilement attaquer un pays,
viser des des hommes qui n'ont pas dans
la frontière de bataille avec vous, avec
toutes les arbres sophistiquées ou des
des planning de
très malicieuse et à partir du moment il
y a une sagesse une sagesse vraiment
apparente, l'Iran serait toujours comme
était sur la la autour de la table de
négociation. Quel pays vous verrez
quel pays vous verrez pour apaiser la
situation ?
la France, la Grande-Bretagne, la
Russie, la Chine, les États-Unis, le
Malaoui, l'Australie,
le Venezuela, la Colombie, quel pays qui
à vos yeux permettrait de négocier le
calme, le retour à la paix, à la
coopération et d'éviter que ça
s'envenime encore plus ? Euh nous euh
vous je vous ai dit avant l'interview,
on ne s'appuie pas euh sur les autres.
Donc nous nous appuyons
sur ce que nous croyons et puis sur
notre peuple et sur notre force
défensive.
Euh
on on est on on voit réalistique les
choses,
on regarde, on conserve, on observe et
les autres aussi observent la ce qui se
passe. et cette injustice qui est là
maintenant depuis quelques décennies
dans notre région et l'instabilité tout
ça
à partir donc c'est pour les instances
internationales et puis s'ils veulent
bien intervenir et puis prévenir de
arrêter le cou du sang parce que nous
nous ne voulons pas eux peut-être ils
ont l'habitude parce que quand on
regarde le cas on voit que combien de
dizaines de milliers de d'enfants et de
femmes et d'hommes ont été tués très
facilement et Israël combien de millions
ont été déplacés ? Mais non, pour nous
ce n'est pas Israël a combien de temps
auprès des institutions internationales
pour fournir les preuves
de vous êtes à deux doigts de jours de
faire une bombe, c'est-à-dire de prouver
cette menace imminente. Combien de temps
? Si vous avez si vous avez trouvé
quelque chose, nous nous avons mais le
euh comme je comme vous avez dit endroit
international le dernier c'était 2009
quand ils ont attaqué notre installation
par STNET mais avant ça Stocknet Ouais
euh par cyberattaque et puis c'est
qu'ils ont Stocksnet pour ceux qui ne
savent pas c'est-à-dire qu' avec un
virus informatique ils ont flingué vos
vos centrifugeuses Oui, tout à fait.
Oui. Donc, mais il y a très longtemps
parce que une stratégie est là
de la mer jusqu'à la rivière.
Donc, c'est un c'est le grand Israël,
c'est ça ? Oui. Oui. Grand Israël. Mais
je ne sais pas comment ils peuvent
vraiment
gérer et
digestiv cette gérer déer de cette cette
partie du monde. Mais on ne peut pas
accepter facilement être victime d'un
gouvernement qui ne pense qu'à qu'à de
coulement de de sang et de de
bombardement aveugle de liquidation.
euh terroriste
vraiment euh voilà les
la situation que qui peut
aller vers le pire ou le l'aisence mais
pour nous il n'y a pas de justification
et il n'y a pas de de preuve. Est-ce
qu'il y a un sujet que vous souhaiteriez
aborder avec nous
qu'on a pas abordé ? On va faire une
interview un peu plus courte aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle était pas prévue. Ouais.
Et je pense que vous avez une semaine un
peu difficile.
Non, on essaie de vraiment de Merci à
vous d'avoir
euh euh
de nous donner cette occasion pour
parler avec d'autres votre spectateur,
votre Vous savez pourquoi on fait ça ?
Qu'on Vous savez pourquoi on parle avec
les gens et qu'on fait parler les gens
parce que du moment que les gens se
parlent, ils évitent de se taper dessus.
Tout à fait. Non non, c'est un c'est un
très bon travail comme j'ai eu de
l'expérience et puis j'ai pu connaître
votre site. Euh non, je n'ai rien parce
que pour nous euh c'est un c'est un
esprit de justice, un esprit de de
liberté vraiment, un esprit de d'éthique
et d'équité est très importante. Euh la
vie court ou longue va finir, mais euh
ce qui reste c'est notre richesse
humaine, notre
notre culture, notre
contact euh humain qui donne la richesse
réelle, vraiment une diversité de la
richesse et puis nous chacun à sa place
a besoin d'essayer de parler, de se
faire connaître, de connaître les autres
et puis d'essayer de ne pas laisser le
monde aille vers un vers un vraiment un
milieu un terrain de de haine et de
d'animosité. C'est c'est à mon avis
c'est on a proposé euh il y a 4 mois en
même temps que notre dernière interview
à l'ambassade d'Israël, on leur a laissé
nos coordonnées, notre numéro de
téléphone pour que euh on leur a indiqué
que notre porte était ouverte pour
discuter. Euh on n'a pas eu de réponse.
Peut-être qu'il vont nous appeler après
cette interview pour discuter, donner
leur point de vue. Si un jour ils nous
disent on est là, si un jour vous êtes
toujours là, est-ce que vous voulez vous
êtes d'accord pour discuter en même
temps autour de ce ensemble en face de
nous ? Euh regardons
euh
bah à un circonst un circonstance
supposé, il faut il faut voir à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce qui va se passer,
qu'est-ce qu'elle est la Mais en
principe vous voyez euh
s'il y a vraiment une un changement vers
une vers une justice même relative
dans toute cette partie du monde
où chaque citoyen réjouit de vivre à
côté des autres et puis de contribuer à
un enrichissement de de la culture, de
l'amitié.
Ça, il n'y a pas besoin vraiment de de
ne même de ne pas avoir des contacts
humains, de ne pas avoir des relations
euh quelconque. Mais ce qui est vraiment
déplorable, c'est que pour des raisons
impensable et
incompréhensible,
il y a un noyeux de guerre, de
destruction, de haine et du sang dans
notre région
qui change chaque fois en frontière
quand on regarde euh l'histoire de ce
parti du monde euh dans
décennies récente euh quel pays vraiment
peut prétendre était à l'abri d'une
menace quelconque ? Vous avez pas
remarqué tous les pays étaient quel est
quel est quel est le point commun dans
la région de tous ces pays où il y a eu
la guerre le sang ? Quel est le point
commun de tous ces pays ? et les
hydrocarbures.
Vous avez pas l'impression qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y a des ressources
énergétiques,
il faut qu'on apporte la démocratie, il
faut qu'on aille voir pour vous apporter
la civilisation. Vous avez pas remarqué
ça à chaque fois ? Non, non, non. Vous
avez raison. C'est un un élément très
très important parce que nous nous
devons être toujours divisés, nous
devons être toujours
calé de de On va apporter la démocratie
au Groenlande dans pas très longtemps.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. nouveau nouveau au
Moyen-Orient avec voilà la démocratie
tout ça mais on vraiment on ne comprend
pas
l'armée la plus morale du monde euh le
pays le plus démocratique de
Moyen-Orient ce sont des un peu
voyez-vous les gens ne comprennent pas
dans notre région c'est tout vous avez
essayé de les comprendre aussi comment
vous avez essayé de les comprendre ils
se sentent entourés avec des gens des
gens autour
agressif à leur égard et la mayonnaise
monte monte monte monte monte monte
monte.
Ou monsieur,
les dirigeants d'un pays ont un très
grand rôle en donnant des occasions de
bien-être ou d'inquiétude de stress à un
peuple.
Euh la vie n'est pas très longue
et le monde très n'est pas très grande
et puis l'humanité n'est pas très petite
si vous voulez dans le sens des des
valeurs. Donc voilà, passer la vie d'un
peuple toujours en guerre, en euh
hostilité, en haine. Ce n'est pas
quelque chose vraiment de
quand je vois l'Europe et j'ai étudié un
peu avant d'être diplomate au cours
quand j'étais diplomate. Donc vous avez
vous êes toujours
non quand j'étais jeune diplomate que
j'essayais voilà de et j'ai vu que vous
avez essayer
de bâtir sur le cendre
des occupations des haines des
animosités
euh une communauté
plus ou moins stable
satisfaisante en tout cas avec peut-être
avec les problèmes que vous sentez bien
comme pas Nous nous sommes notre peuple
est hors de cette région, mais pour nous
dans la région ce n'était pas le cas.
Vous voyez ?
Ils ont commencé cette déstabilisation
continue au Moyen-Orient
une fois par une agression d'un état à
d'autres état une fois par création des
groupes et groupuscules avec l'étiquette
islamique tout ça mais très extrémistes
euh ennemi de tout le monde avec
vraiment un comportement
sauvage
On se souvient de le dais,
on se souvient comment ils ont été
alimentés et et faire pénétrer, exfiltré
dans cette région et qui était là pour
défendre et pour faire barrage à cette à
ce groupelà. Sinon aujourd'hui, on avait
une région
divisée par les différents groupes
extrémistes qui n'avaient aucunement
l'intention de vivre en paix ou enité.
L'économie du monde qui dépend du parti
de cette région aurait été abîmée. Mais
bon, c'est c'est un peu le cas quand
même on arrive à la fin de notre
interview.
Euh, il y a deux Français qui sont
encore dans vos prisons,
on accélère un peu le processus, on les
libère, on les récupère à Orlie.
C'est vraiment c'est dommage. Regardons
euh nous ne voulons pas avoir un
ressortissant étranger en prison en
Iran. L'autre fois, je vous ai dit et
nous ne voulons même avoir notre
ressortissant en prison à l'étranger.
Mais dans nos jours, te parler qu'il
faut qu'il n'y ait pas aucun
ressortissant dans les prisons à
l'étranger. C'est un utopia, c'est pas
possible parce que l'homme est faible à
à tout délit ou que ce type de choses.
Donc nous n'avions nous avions des cas
iraniens ici, français en Iran et nous
avons beaucoup de détenus maintenant à
l'étranger au pays limétrovins
mais au-delà aussi en Turquie. Ils sont
détenus parce qu'ils ont fait des
bêtises ou ils sont détenus parce qu'ils
ont fait du renseignement ? Non, il
regardons dans l'ensemble parler en
généralité,
il y a toujours
des activités inadaptées
à la loi des pays,
que ça soit économique, je ne sais pas
politique ou tout ça. Pour nous, on ne
souhaitait jamais avoir un détenu
français. C'est pourquoi les dirigeants
ou l'opinion publique nous demandent de
faire libérer de libérer ce que nous
voulons vraiment. Mais il y a la
justice, il y a un procès comme partout
comme nous avons ici la même chose. Mais
cela n'empêche pas que
nous ayons une en tout cas une relation
une histoire des relations plus ou moins
équilibré avec la France.
Quand nous avions eu ici des des
détenus, on avait un approche. Il y a eu
des
pour parler comment des pour parler.
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Donc nous voulons
vraiment aider à la libération aussitôt
que possible. C'est pourquoi euh dans
l'accord entre le présidents de la
République des deux pays euh les
instances concernées ont été en contact
et le ministère des affaires étrangères
sur cette sous cette brèle-elà. nous
avons réussi de de faire euh libérer par
la justice euh
cinq ressortis en français
mais de reste
pour eux tout en essayant de faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas une approche, un
comportement discriminatoire
par rapport aux autres iraniens détenus
en Iran.
euh même tout en leur euh donnant les
facilités qu'on ne donne pas au
ressortissant iranien dans les prisons
iranienes
dans la dans la mesure de possible par
exemple des internet la télévision l'eau
chaude ça je ne sais pas mais parfois il
il les amèneent dans les villas privés
pour qu'ils puissent être un peu à
l'aise au de la de de de de la de
l'environnement de la prison dans la
dans la mesure de possible. Je je vous
dis euh
c'est une un comportement non
discriminatoire. C'est un une ligne de
conduite pour l'Iran en ce qui concerne
les ressortissants français pour
lesquels vraiment personnellement et
comme un ambassadeur d'Iran, j'espère
euh qu'on puisse accélérer la procédure
et faire entrer sa et sauf vers leur
famille. Vous avez attrapé des gens du
Mossade récemment.
En Iran ? Vous voyez, c'est la même
chose en Iran, ce sont des questions de
jour hier, avant-hier, aujourd'hui, même
avant parce que euh nous avons
un a été euh puni aujourd'hui même ou
hier. Quel type de punition ? Non, nous
avons un punition de
de peine de mort. Nous avons c'est légal
en Iran. C'est très rare mais c'est
légal dans ce type combien il y a eu
combien de de morts par peine de mort
cette année iranien confondu ? pas trop,
pas trop mais les fluff sont sont liées
aux drogues. sont liées aux drogues.
Voilà, nous comme je vous ai dit, on est
très rare. Nous avons parce que sur
l'aspect juridique et dans les lois, il
y a aussi la peine de mort pour quelques
crimes.
Mais le gouvernement depuis longtemps,
l'État a essayé de vraiment faciliter
des punitions successives.
Comment succession ? Au lieu de faire la
peine de mort, on fait la prison avec
quelques euh amende si vous voulez comme
ça pour éviter vraiment que Si je fume
un joint en Iran du haschich, j'ai la
peine de mort. Non, Hachich n'est pas
n'a pas la peine de mort. Hash haschich
iranien. Non, le mot
comment ? Non non non. Hachich n'est pas
iranien.
Euh non. Mais il y a il y a des il y a
une vois très près. C'est combien
d'années de prison pour un joint ?
Comment c'est combien d'années de prison
pour un joint ? Pour un un joint Si je
fume un joint en Iran. Un joint c'est
quoi un joint ? Un un joint de Hach. Oh
non c'est pas ce n'est pas tu vas en
prison. Non non non. À partir du moment
où vous n'êtes pas un vendeur, un
dealer, un
si vous trouvez vous faites. Si vous
trouvez pas,
pas vu, pas pris. Ah pris ça.
Bon euh est-ce que vous avez trois
livres à nous conseiller ?
Les livres, vous voyez
les des livres pour la paix. Comment ?
Des livres pour la paix.
Vous savez, la littérature iranienne est
très riche. et nous avons des des poètes
et des écrivains euh avec une ancienneté
1000 ans il y a par exemple.
Donc euh pour un étranger, je crois les
poet iraniens ont une source et un moyen
de connaître la culture iranienne qui
est une culture de paix de et et de
respect et de la tolérance et de la
coésistance. C'est c'est ça l'Iran et le
peuple iranien, la nation iranienne.
Donc euh les livres de Hafè, de Molavi,
de Sais Chzi, ce sont des livres et je
crois que les Européens adorent. Euh
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer ? leur je leur
souhaite la meilleure vie comme je la
souhaite pour mes enfants, mes fils.
Monsieur l'ambassade,
monsieur l'ambassadeur Mohamed Aminjad,
ambassadeur de la République islamique
d'Iran. Merci. Merci à vous.
[Musique]